hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcasted
ah I'm just checking in on you yeah I
felt like that was really loud when I
first came out I apologize to anybody
just startled on an elliptical oh my god
I just you know this [__] elliptical
remember when you were King and just
like getting out of bed with doing the
elliptical and you went downstairs and a
fudgie wudgie for [__] breakfast
fudgie wudgie was away my fudgy what
fudgie the whale remember that for
[__] the Mose that ice cream store
called out there on the East Coast and
introducing fudgie the whale it always
looked like a big [__] I don't know
look like a big flounder that someone
took a [__] on you don't as much as I
had a sweet tooth as a kid I never had
any does a Carvel ice cream had fudgie
the whale
fudgie the whale they were on the
cutting edge they saw the direction this
country was headed in it's like these
people are eating and they're not
stopping okay this is not a trend this
is the way it's gonna be
we need to jump on this let's get some
ideas for some cakes what do we got here
what's the biggest fish a whale a
[__] whale man a whale covered in
chocolate and then you freeze it and
it's actually ice cream but it's also
it's also a [__] whale so if it's a
[__] [__] show that's that's why
we're gonna make it brown that's gonna
be the theme it's a [__] show and right
as you're thinking like oh my god I
can't believe I just [__] ate that
you're gonna pass out from from the from
the ice cream headache you know what's
amazing about super overweight people is
somebody at some point in their life sat
down and ate one of those in one sitting
by themselves you know like [__]
Belushi in the Cabana out there at that
[__] hotel down there where you go to
die whatever the [__] it's called
Chateau Mom all right
speedballing except the ice-cream cake
version of it if you went Belushi on
that cake that meant you sat down and
you ate an entire [__] fudgie the
whale yourself you know what I got to
look that [__] up now I got to see what
exactly you know I mean like when you
want to know when it went a quarter back
played in the NFL when was fudgie the
whale
fudgie the whale you know what's crazy
there's probably a whole Wikipedia page
about it fudgie the whale was a Fame oh
my God look at that [__] thing there
is a Wikipedia page that's hilarious all
right
fudgie the whale is a type of ice cream
cake it still exists still playing in
the league it's like Tom Brady but it's
a cake produced and sold by Carvel in
its franchise stores it was developed by
Cavell in the 70s as an expansive
expansion of its line of freshly made
products the [__] is fresh about that
thing yeah we just made that [__] along
with hug me bear and cookie puss that
was another thing they knew porno was
taken off these fat these people are
gonna eat so much they're gonna they're
not going to get any [__] so they're
gonna start watching porn so we're gonna
make cookie puss I partnership branding
in the media development although the
cake depicts the shape of a whale and
was originally decorated as such it was
sometimes adapted for holiday use by
rotating at 90 degrees counterclockwise
so the whales body now upright could
represent a face wait a minute but it's
it's it's then it would be in that whale
would be in blackface Jesus Christ the
[__] you could do in the 70s you have a
blackface [__] ice cream cake for
Christmas and nobody blinked well I'm
sure people blinked but nobody said
anything cookie puss now there's the one
right there that's the acid trip one
that is disgusting says cookie puss and
it's noses and up to upside-down ice
cream cone just a cone and then the tip
of his nose is green and it says egg on
it green egg has little arms all right I
don't know what part of the internet I'm
on but I feel like I'm get
on a watch list here let's shut this
[__] off anyway anyway it is ladies and
gentlemen I am only a few days away from
my latest special paper tiger it's
coming out I saw the first billboard
last night drive it along out here in LA
got very excited that was what I was
yeah I was like it was that [__] bald
guy with hair plugs and I looked in who
was it it was old yours truly anyway but
last night
better than my special coming out I went
I saw once upon a time in Hollywood
again it was even better the second time
and I am I am convinced it's Leonardo
DiCaprio's greatest performance the
level of I might have to see it a third
time just to catch all this [__] that he
was doing I'm not you know no disrespect
to any all the other actors out there
but Jesus Christ the first time you see
it like oh my god Brad Pitt is the
[__] dude I want to be but the second
time you watch it you're like oh my god
I'm Leonardo DiCaprio I relate to what
he's going through [__] amazing god
it's a [__] experience and I actually
went down this time like a total movie
nerd I went down to the Beverly cinema
which Tarantino bought and you go down
there the sells out like every night and
I went down there and they had this guy
out on the street selling all this cool
merch like t-shirts and like you could
get a button Brad Pitt's dog I don't
want to ruin any of the names of anybody
or anything in it but you know they had
a couple of posters from the movie
hanging in the lobby old school snacks
they had candy cigarettes dads root beer
all of this [__] from way back in the
day incredible incredible gonna [__]
go again I don't give a [__] as long as
it's [__] playing down there I'm just
gonna I'm gonna keep seeing it till I'm
sick of it
tremendous tremendous [__] movie
there's so much [__] I want to say too
but I don't want to ruin it for anybody
just go out go see the goddamn thing
alright and with that we are only what's
today Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday
three days away boo put it away the
start of the NFL season as far as I know
I believe it is of course I'll be on an
airplane when it starts the New England
Patriots your defending Super Bowl
champion for the 6th [__] time trying
to go back-to-back having lost some key
people to free agency and retiring can
they do it again who knows who knows you
got to get lucky like last year he
played the [__] Rams we got lucky
Todd Gurley got hurt I mean that changed
the whole [__] face of the game which
I thought was really interesting
considered right now our Super Bowl
championships are bookended by beating
the LA the love Rams franchise st. Louis
the first time Los Angeles I don't give
a [__] where that team is playing out of
we beat him in the Superbowl and they're
running back is either not used or gets
hurt
the first time for whatever reason they
didn't use Marshall [__] I think that
they it's almost like a fighter who's a
boxer and he gets sucked into a brawl
they got sucked in Mike Martz got sucked
into whatever the [__] we were doing and
forgot that he had the greatest [__]
running back in the league at that point
and then last year we lucked out where
they got hurt you know you need a little
bit of luck the helmet catch they let's
not give it to [__] Marshawn Lynch
and throw it you can go either way
little bit of luck a little bit of luck
sometimes on those close games can't see
helmet catch because that was a great
skill thing I would say the [__] I
don't know if the that the second giant
loss that we had were they [__] threw
the ball he's got two guys in his face
he just [__] throws it up in the air
and it landed perfectly but then it's
like well that's the second time he did
it so is it luck or is that just the
pain of me losing I don't know whatever
but I definitely I'll take all three of
those losses to to the Giants one of the
Eagles to Winston that's what we did
I'm still waiting for my rings that said
college football's in full swing maybe
get a couple of - two or three good
games calls football so weird in the
beginning where it's just literally
let's watch an eighth-grader fight a
first-grader it's the first two three
weeks of the season they've gotten
better at it they've sort of you know
leveled out a little more with the
scholarships which is made for some
great upsets I can't get rid of this
[__] cough I swear to god it's that
goddamn black mold they go out there I
was breathing it in I think I got rid of
it though I think it's I got to get
somebody over here if I can figure out
what's going on maybe I have a large and
do we have any lodgings here excuse me
could I trouble you for a lodging but
anyway as always I have no [__] time
in my day I'm running around like a
lunatic and I'm dealing with the fact
that my lovely daughter has now decided
to assert herself because I was sitting
there going like terrible twos what the
hell is this talking about she's in
wouldn't we talk this kids an absolute
sweetheart and now right about the
midway point between 2:00 and 3:00 all
of a sudden she's doing this now no
thank you I don't want it that's what
just say way come on we gotta go we
gotta give you a bath no thank you I
don't want it then you just guys sit
there and laugh then she gets mad that
you laugh there really is no proper
response so I don't know I'm just
[__] deal with it but about what I am
happy with this I have really learned
that I'm not gonna be a raving lunatic
screaming and yelling parent granted I'm
just dealing with the toddler but I
don't have you know my temper has really
ruined a lot of events and aspects in my
life and I don't plan on anything with
my kid being one of those events so so
far so good two and a half years down
[__] fifteen and a half to go
all I gotta do is just hold my temper
for another decade and a half you know
although I kind of upset my wife already
this morning I woke up
bulu do it and I couldn't find my
flashcards I'd outline the first chapter
and a half of the the test the pilot
testing for [__] your instrument
training and I couldn't find my cards
and I and I was maintaining it
I was maintaining my [__] nose like
alright whatever it's only a gentleman
lost a chapter and a half I could have
lost all eight chapters I could have
done that and you know that my wife let
me know I'm not feeling well you know
she says that as I'm I told her I'm
looking for my cards I'm not feeling
well where do you have somewhere to be
and I kind of snapped I said I'm gonna
watch her I get it you don't feel well
and then it turned out she was just
asking to see if I had a lesson to know
I end up being a hundred percent and
wrong and I found my flashcards you know
when you're that wrong you know you're
so [__] wrong that your wife loves it
you know and then you got to be like oh
I thought you were saying that because
of this and I found my flesh I have even
told her I found my flash cards yet I
gotta tell her that when I go in which
is the right thing to do cuz then it's
just total shame totally feel like a
[__] [__] and then they feel
validated and they feel great cuz no
matter what's going around it's about
their emotions I had such a fun set the
other night I ran my hour cuz I got the
special next week if I haven't mentioned
9 million times and I got Vegas this
weekend and I've already done the hour
that's part of my special last time I
was out there and I just have to make
sure that I do something totally
different even though it's a transient
City so I went over to flap and did a
little over an hour and the best time
that [__] bit I'm doing about
lesbians that had the two ladies yell at
me and then wait to yell at me some more
and [__] thought I was the biggest
caveman ever there was two women in the
front row holding hands
a couple or they saw something horrific
before they came into the show and they
were using each other emotionally I did
the bit and they [__] loved it they
would die and laughing so there we go
there we go having said that I'm sure if
I put it on a special people will
continue to freak out and flip out by
people I mean like 3% of the population
I had somebody who's not a comedian
actually text me and be like dude can
you please explain to me why everybody
is flipping out about that Chappell
Chappell special and I go they aren't
they aren't it's a very small portion of
the [__] population is waving their
arms and then every news agency picks up
on that why because they care
no because upset people makes the
[__] news all right if people waving
in desperate situations always made the
news
the [__] drug epidemic this 15
[__] year war or whatever we're in
wouldn't have gotten this out of control
all right but they so then what do they
do 28 people holding up [__] signs
they put on a goddamn cue card becomes a
[__] you know firestorm and I was
saying like dude nobody I went to the
supermarket people are fine
no one was standing there going oh my
god I can't get these apples because of
these jokes I heard jokes we're flipping
out about jokes but we're ignoring
[__] the country going bankrupt
country country being bankrupt we're
ignoring that that's not a [__] story
they're finally coming around to a whoa
what's going on with the drug epidemic
and I read something in the in the the
Sunday paper my favorite old man thing
to do get a Sunday paper and sit down
and act like you're a man of the world
and want to know what's going on they
actually had the nerve to call fentanyl
they started calling it Mexican fentanyl
this Mexican fentanyl that's coming in
and all these mouth-breathing [__]
you got their Mexican [__] right now
fentanyl like coca-cola is us we started
that [__] as far as I know I didn't
research the Fed I don't know where it
came from Nazi doctors I have no idea
it's been around for a while right but
now but in the
I don't know how many years they made it
[__] went out into the mainstream and
as far as Bryant Gumbel's sports real
sports
these kids were given these [__]
opioids like football players and then
when they run on the prescription
they're addicted and then they turn to
heroin
so the heroin I guess market skyrocket
but making heroines a pain in the
[__] ass growing a [__] you know
crop what's going to happen them locusts
gonna come in and [__] mainline all
my poppy seeds that's the southern
Mexican and that was what that really
spice was right there so they were all
we can just you know people flying over
seeing our crops they [__] come in
and they burn them down as a pain and
[__] ass the evidence is just sitting
outside you can't even hide it or we
could just make the pills ourselves so
now they're making them the same way
they making coca-cola down there the way
we used to up here with real pure 100%
imported sugar you know that's why the
Mexican Coke is better I don't know if
you guys have it where you're from
Mexican coke they make coke better than
we make coke American coke America
stinks it's not as good as Mexican coke
makes no [__] sense whatsoever you
know that's like that making American
cars not in America why would they do
that why wait what's going on here but
none of that's a [__] issue none of
that's a [__] issue oh my god did you
hear the knock-knock joke somebody
[__] told Jesus Christ is that gonna
change society well society as we know
it not be able to survive because
somebody did a joke about a
gender-neutral bathroom wroom wroom
wroom yeah it's all [__] it's a
misdirection man anyway sorry I'm on a
little bit of a [__] tangent here
alright so I go to my follow-up
appointment today with my doctor for my
very close vein which seems to be
healing nicely although I keep getting a
reoccurring bruise goes away and then it
comes back goes away and it comes back I
know all you guys are gonna go on
[__] WebMD be like you got something
of internal bleeding I don't need your
[__] explanations okay this pastie as
I am I'm borderline transparent alright
there are no secrets within my body
they're right there on the surface any
doctor can come in and just read me like
a [__] roadmap right
those are my doctor appointments they
don't have to probe they know if they do
anything I just take my clothes off and
stand there naked I got you problem you
got a fatty liver conceived from across
the room here Jesus Christ do you ever
get out in the Sun I'm gonna give you a
prescription for whatever vitamin what
vitamin does the Sun give you know
vitamin C for cancer now Jesus it's my
[__] booking agent oh no oh no what
is this I gotta take this hang on I
gotta hit pause alright I'm back he's
back and he's dumber than ever
alright I just found out got my
[__] I got my patch tickets for
the Patriots versus the [__] Redskins
I will be there not being a jerk I'm not
gonna be sitting there wearing a bunch
of Patriots [__] screaming and yelling
I'm going to sit there respectfully and
root for my team and not be a [__]
[__] that's it
you know that's what I do you know why
because I really really enjoy not
getting the [__] kicked out of me in
somebody else's [__] football stadium
I don't need to do that okay I came
close enough that time I took a leak it
dead that's inside the stadium and the
Buffalo Bills those [__]
piece-of-shit fans I'll tell you there
is a reason why they've never won a
Super Bowl and God put that Lake there
to just rain snow on them for [__]
nine months out of the year there is a
reason those people deserve it okay and
I bet if you go back and if you would a
dig if you could somehow get through
that frozen tundra through the what's
buried in that [__] soil you know
everything from Native Americans to
[__] altar boys
sorry that one went dark what do you
[__] want from me okay I'm just a
borderline literate [__] bald [__]
redheaded male just trying to get
through a goddamn podcast that's all
just trying to make ends meet with my
own little internet radio show speaking
of which we have some advertising here
this is a new one Oh max what are you
doing Oh max problem okay they're
getting right to it whether you're an
athlete weekend warrior are someone who
deals with constant joint pain back pain
muscle soreness or arthritis finding a
natural remedy that instantly works
might seem non-existent most
over-the-counter pain relievers such as
icy hot and bengay fire calling out
products by name only focus on one basic
cooling effect such as menthol oh yeah
mentholyptus which temporary takes your
mind off the pain until that pain
returns in an hour or so if you're
looking to get rid of nagging muscle and
joint pain immediately while providing
long lasting recovery then you need all
capitals name to try the natural
breakthrough pain relief solution imma
try this [__] on my knee relief solution
cryofreeze CBD developed by ohm max
health o max health this quick absorbing
scientifically backed formula provides
pain relief instantly this
non-prescription triple action pain
relief roll-on is specially formulated
to block pain receptors reduce
inflammation and improve muscle and
joint flexibility those last two are
really important because we have plenty
of [__] that just blocks pain receptors
but actually it looks like it actually
helps the problem the best part is this
is 100% natural CBD powdered remedy
works its magic within 10 minutes of
application and relief lasts up to eight
hours much longer than over-the-counter
products it's super easy to throw on in
your gym
it's super easy to throw in your gym bag
and take on the go for emergency pain
relief simply roll it on over where it
hurts and ice out the pain with an
arctic blast yeah if you know how to use
deodorant you'll find CTA whatever that
means
Oh max health is offering my listeners
20% off a full bottle of cryofreeze pain
relief roll-on plus free shipping this
discount also applies towards any
products site-wide just go - Oh max dot
health.com oh ma X HEA LTH calm today
and enter the code BRR X all lowercase
all one word bu r RX they have it in
quotes I don't know if you have to put
in quotes - to take advantage of this
incredible savings that's Oh m ax HEA
LTH calm and center and enter the code
birth to get BER X to get 20% or maybe
it's just BER
I think it's BER the other one was a
typo I don't [__] know to get 20% off
cryofreeze site wise Oh max you've done
it again alright hello fresh hmm
cook meals made simple that's
capitalized I'm just going to start
yelling anytime they capitalize an
entire word okay hello fresh cooked
meals mates hello fresh makes cooking
eat delicious meals at home a reality
regardless of your comfort in the
kitchen terrible things happen to me in
there with a stick of butter from
step-by-step recipes to probably think I
just lost an advertiser from
step-by-step recipes to pre-measured
ingredients you'll have everything you
need to get a WoW worthy dinner on the
table in just about 30 minutes say
goodbye to endless grocery store trips
and takeout food hello fresh hi has she
covered break out break out of your
dinner rut with hellofresh 20 plus
seasonal chef curated recipes each week
there's something for everyone I love
that word curated you mean you picked it
yourself everyone's always trying to a
specially curated the
something for everyone my clothes that I
wore today we're curated I picked them
out myself and I changed my t-shirt
twice that's when it becomes curated
rather than just throwing something on
there's something for everyone from
family recipes to calories Matt and
vegetarian and fun menu series like Hall
of Fame and craft burgers host must
voice unique hellofresh vanity URL
special offer and unique promo code will
[__] give it to me oh here it is for
80 dollars off your first month of hello
fresh go to hello fresh com / bur 80 and
enter berate EP you are r80
repeat offer vanity URL and Pro Mon
going to well this is just lazy copy and
pasting here
this isn't therefore it's like receiving
eight meals for free or you get $20 off
your first four boxes okay for 80
dollars off your first month of
hellofresh go to hello fresh com hello
fresh com
/ / 80 and enter bur 80 alright last one
put your box ah my favorite
yummy yummy but your box makes it easy
to get high-quality humanely raised meat
that you can trust huh can I trust you
Pig can I tell you this story and know
that it ends here every month butcher
box delivers 100% grass-fed and
grass-finished beef free-range orange
organic chicken sorry heritage breed
pork that my favorite best pork chop I
ever had and wild Alaskan salmon you
don't know what directly to your door
and shipping is free choose from four
curated boxes I select that chicken or
customize your own box so that you can
get exactly what you and your family
love each box comes with least nine
eleven nine to eleven pounds of meat I'm
sorry that we were going September 11th
9 to 11 pounds of meat which is enough
for 24 individual size meals or one of
those skinny Asian dudes what he [__]
is gonna win a nut of title there in
Coney Island he's gonna meat is frozen
at the peak of freshness in individual
vacuum sealed packs all meat is
delivered right to your doorstep with
free shipping
my favorite cut is the heritage breed
pork I've told you a thousand times best
pork chop I ever had absolutely [__]
delicious new subscribers will receive
ground beef for life
that's right sign up today and butcher
bucks will send you two pounds of 100%
grass-fed beef free and every box for
the life of your subscription $20 off
your first go to box 20 $20 off your
first box go to butcher bucks calm / /
or enter the promo code bar at checkout
that's butcher box calm / / or enter the
promo code birth that's all in capitals
I just don't yell anymore be URR all
capitals at checkout all right there we
go and where are we here in the
recording because I gotta go to the doc
all right 14 and change + 8 9 and change
is 9 and change that's 25 minutes
alright I got 5 minutes the [__] my
favorite thing to do in the world
just just [__] what are you doing ah
man I'm just bullshitting I was just
[__] with you just farted just having
a good [__] time alright so it begins
this weekend my first I feel like really
official show that I've got to be doing
with my special looming in the future
and I'm going hard man I can't wait I am
NOT smoked a cigar
since Tuesday last week what is that 9
days that's all I have to do just once
every couple of weeks I just smoke one
cuz then all during those hope to two
weeks I just look back fondly on the
last one that I smoked and in
anticipation of the next one rather than
smoking like a [__] fiend three four
seven in a week then I just hate myself
going what am i doing what am i I got to
stop doing this I got to stop doing this
I got to stop doing this you know then I
don't enjoy it it's just a giant guilt
trip but if I do it once every two weeks
I mean come on I mean that's that's how
a gentleman does it everything in
moderation it's my mom always said
everything in moderation just do
everything
in moderation well I'm a lunatic so I
don't know how to [__] do that psycho
I like that let me get let me continue
doing that are you guys starting to do
it like I try to monitor my I'm trying
to do that now like even just [__] that
like won't put you out on the street
like right now I have a I have a little
bit of a problem with peanut M&Ms do you
imagine me going on in a documentary
about addiction right and it's all these
[__] horrible things for people you
know lost their lives and lost their
families and lost where they live
families not talking about them and then
they get to me and I just sit there and
I'm tearing up and going through the
exact same level of pain there's these
other people and all I all I'm talking
about is peanut M&Ms I can't lay off
them and I'll tell you right now if you
Eminem's now makes like literally one of
those like you know those bags they put
over a horse's mouth when they're eating
oats they have a bag like that and it
says family size but you know goddamn
well you know you're eating it yourself
so there's one that's like almonds and
that is the [__] one I get that one I
swear to god I take my hands off the
wheel
you think texting and driving is bad you
get me a bag of those [__] M&Ms
that's it I have to literally I have to
grab a handful Rees if the [__] thing
and stick it up on the top shelf and
just like walk away and just be and then
be like totally aware after I eat five
of them to be sitting there going like
you don't want any more that's the sugar
right now telling you to go get some
more you have to [__] ignore that and
just sit here for about 11 minutes and
then that craving will go away and then
what you did was you had portion control
which M&Ms tries to help you it says
it's 140 calories per serving if you do
one of their portions which i think is
about five M&Ms I don't know what it is
I have no [__] idea I don't even want
to know completely I'll be you know this
is gonna reason why I'm bringing this
[__] up is because as I try to [__]
clean up my life it's like when I when I
put out the fire
in one area something else just starts
[__] flaming up and I think that
that's why people say everything in
moderation because then you're getting
warmed by the fire rather than it
haven't you're burning your house down
and just the balance of life is if you
could totally stomp out one [__] fire
another one just as big begins maybe not
with the same ramifications like if you
look at all these AAA people all these
[__] dry drunks there's something
that they're doing to fill that [__]
void like you know I got one of my
buddies he [__] you know it was food
I got another buddy its cigars you know
I only have like I got one friend of
mine who's a sober friend who I feel
like he put out the drug-and-alcohol
fire and then like didn't become fat
didn't become a lunatic smoker doesn't
[__] he doughnut so I guess that's
the same thing usually smoking or eating
seems to be the [__] thing so I'm
coming up on three hundred days and
approaching three hundred days I now
feel like I'm one of those annoying
[__] people who can't shut the [__]
up about what the [__] it is that
they're doing
you know the people that I used to hate
when I was drinking you know when I was
just going like I still hate them you
know I hate when people do exactly what
I'm doing right now but when I'm doing
what I hate what other people are doing
I want you to sit there and listen to it
I'm just going for 368 days 3 or 69 days
then I break the record then after that
I don't know I will tell you if I see
that once upon a time in Hollywood again
and you know the drinking and smoking
that goes on in there you know one of my
favorite [__] things in the world is
to see somebody in a movie drinking and
smoking in their house and if it's a
[__] cigar I always look at it like
Jesus Christ like that guy
that guy figured it out you know this is
a deal if you can [__] be at home in
a silk [__] robe and slippers and you
have like a [__] like a crazy TV room
alright and you can sit in there with
your wife or girlfriend smoking a [__]
cigar while drinking a drink during the
middle of the week like you need to
write a book I want to know how the [__]
that's done actually I don't because
then I'll [__] I don't know it's a tough
thing what do you do you just do the
thing you love to do and diet 59 or do
you not do the thing you [__] love be
around for people that love you and just
have this extra thirty years of misery I
mean it's a twenty years of misery I
mean it's a [__] choice
choice that needs to be made all right
with that I can't [__] wait to go to
Vegas and then you know I told you I'm
gonna go see [__] Elton John the next
day Rock I I love every song he's ever
done except for the Lion King one I just
I just you know I was in a bad part of
my life when that song came out my life
was really bad really dark really
horrible and that was this upbeat oh no
I can't and everybody was like playing
it and [__] loving it and taking their
kid to it and all of that [__] so I
don't know I think I'll be alright but I
you know I wanted to play all that
[__] 70 [__] that's what I want you
know I ran it I I'm still standing
anything but and that anything before
has this right looking forward to that
and I think that's it that's basically
the podcast congratulations to everybody
who's a football fan NFL starts this
week you got college football on
Saturday I mean I don't know how it gets
any I'm gonna be in Vegas for college
[__]
football and I'm gonna be in a sports
book somewhere smoking imagining just
sin imagines this is my house you know
and everything worked and there was no
black mold galvanized pipe and
everything else I've dealt with in this
[__] house and I'm gonna have a great
goddamn time and I'm gonna have a killer
[__] show and I want to thank
everybody that's coming out to see me
and I'm working with an old buddy of
mine that started out with me and Boston
days the great Rick Thalia and my buddy
Dean Delray those two will be open and
hit yeah [__] soft me up then I'm
gonna come over and hit you over the
[__] head I'm gonna smile and wave you
guys gonna go out and gamble and win
some money hopefully and I'm gonna go in
the back and smoke a [__] cigar with
my lovely lady you know watch a little
college football and then go see Elton
John the next day that's my [__]
weekend and I hope all you guys have as
great a weekend lined up his ID to go
Pat's Patriots Steelers right out of the
gate do the Steelers and the [__]
misery if they win the game well the
referees let them win at this time nope
all of these questions will be answered
come this Sunday all right don't forget
to go to church moto gp another race I
don't even know where they're at but all
I know it's is it's gonna be amazing and
Marc Marquez lost on the last turn of
the last two races so I think he's going
to be [__] driving like an extra
lunatic with any luck that man will not
be in first place at the beginning of
the race and then you get to watch him
drive around and a lot of times through
the other people in front I don't know
how he does it he literally like
sideswipes people you know and and he
somehow he doesn't fall the other person
Falls or he takes part of their
motorcycle oh that he might that happen
to him I think the vit C also took one
of his pegs off for some [__] and one of
the races I know it's [__] amazing
and I have to watch that last Formula
One race where Ferrari won which is
great I hope they start winning some
more because nothing would be nothing
would be better for that sport if they
could be some competition for Lewis
Hamilton all right that is
it god bless all you have a great
weekend you [__] I'll check in on your
Monday I mean I'll give you a podcast on
Monday and enjoy the music and then we
have an extra half-hour of bonus there's
the
before I honeymooned podcast from the
Hillsdale
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday
September 15 2011
happy [__] Labor Day oh my god GTI
can you believe it it's the end of the
summer
no more dressing like oh I can already
feel at the bottom of my bum cheeks
they're not gonna be as tan the leaves
are changing color just like my ass oh
[Laughter]
how about a [__] round of applause
for the drunk horse who spilled wine
coolers on their little white [__]
coochie cutters isn't that great
turns a little bit pink and they sit
there with their club soda and it looks
like they're trying to finger their [__]
but they don't know where it is you know
that just to the left of it I can't get
the [__] stain off Masha
do you have another pair of [__]
horse shorts that I can wear around the
[__] beach and attract some of the
dumbest [__] men possible and then I
can [__] about my life and say that all
I meet is [__] despite the fact I
have my [__] lips hanging out happy
Labor Day everybody and I was gonna tell
you guys a little something about Labor
Day but there's nothing interesting
about it you know in case you weren't if
you're too lazy to go on to Wikipedia
and look up Labor Day evidently Labor
Day is with the United States federal
holiday so called White Bear and it was
that's the first Monday in September the
history of Labor Day started in 1918 82
that gives a [__] right there was
nothing in it all I know is just
basically it's supposed to celebrate the
American worker you know that guy who
used to make stuff in this country
remember that do you guys remember that
[__] back in the day when you'd have
those guys dressed in their blue on blue
Dickies and you'd go you go to do Sun
you got to reach for a bottle of ketchup
or you go to you know grab your raise
blade and he'd be like I make DOS me and
my buddies we make all of those for a
whole [__] country and they had pride
because they made razor blades and they
make ketchup bottles then the same
goddamn Factory you know and now what
now it all [__] left because agreed
everybody wanted more and now it's all
[__] gone and now I'm seeing [__] on
the internet go and you know how are we
gonna compete with China I'll tell ya
we're gonna compete with them we're
gonna do the old Packers sweep that's
what we should do and [__] bring the
[__] factories back here everybody
you know what it is everybody's got to
stop being a greedy [__] from the CEO at
the top to the douchey wants to get the
union job so he can lean on a [__]
shovel and milk the clock I blame all of
you and I don't look at my life and find
any fault because I'm an American
everything I do is right and everything
you guys do is wrong you're greedy not
me you know I made myself a tuna
sandwich yesterday I was full three
quarters of the way way through and then
I finished it because I knew that
there's some kid [__] out on an
iceberg up there in Alaska she went on
whale blubber and he would kill for that
[__] tuna sandwich you know so
there's a little story for your CEOs and
union workers why don't you think about
that next time you guys ask for more
[__] money think about think about a
saint like me and my tuna fish sandwich
all right and if that's if that [__]
story didn't make any sense to you then
I got to be honestly I really can't help
you all right do the [__] math oh
[__]
I don't want to do this podcast today I
don't even think I'm gonna be funny I'm
just gonna make [__] up do you guys hear
about Libya [__] slid right into the
ocean you know I know you didn't see it
on the news that's because they don't
want you to know you know you're living
over here in a fishbowl I know what's
going on I went to what's the deal with
Libya calm
why do they call it labor day if nobody
works what are you guys doing to
celebrate the end of the summer you
putting your boat away you're taking it
out one more time contemplating hitting
your wife in the back of the head and
saying it was a boating accident tire
lard-ass to a [__] one water-ski and
just you know what would you do let's
you know let's make that more modern how
do you dispose of a body nowadays back
in the day you gave them gave them
concrete shoes I think nowadays what you
do is you take out two old laptops from
the early [__] 2000 you strap him to
her feet you just throw her overboard
you know and then you just say that she
was uh I don't know what the [__] you
say you ask for a [__] lawyer that's
what you do you don't you don't say
anything that's what I've learned
watching the first 48 you don't say
anything you just sit there where were
you Tuesday July 9th
I might being charged with anything sir
where were I'm not answering that
am I being charged as anything if I'm
not I'm leaving if I am I'm getting a
lawyer that's all you do that's what I
learned on the first 48 but it's scary
scary to stand up to cops you know I
think that that's like what you'd like
to think that you did I think that on
the first 48 they just show all the good
[__] where they don't slap the living
[__] out of somebody and they basically
they solve all the murders on that show
you know they don't show the ones I
don't there's been a couple of guys I
guess what it might what are we five
minutes oh six minutes it is enjoyable
um here's an article that somebody sent
me I'll [__] that if I go right into the
articles then I'm gonna be reading for
55 minutes in this podcast is gonna suck
now goddamn it bill [__] man up and
tell a goddamn story all right you want
to hear a story I was I'm desperately
desperately trying to get back on my
diet oh my god my stomach is hanging
over my trousers no I went on the road
for two and a half weeks since try as
much as I as I could to try to do my
road diet which is to have oatmeal in
the morning some sort of salad with a
[__] slab of fish you know stay away
from the booze that's what I try to do
okay and I can do that for the most part
for a weekend if I'm on the road like
this week I'm going out to Columbus Ohio
alright I'm playing the funny bone down
at the mall everybody all right a lot of
you guys you take me for granted you
know guys don't realize how big I am at
this point I am paying playing the funny
bone comedy club at the mall in Columbus
Ohio okay that don't you guys wish that
you took some chances in your life huh
so you could stand dance like a monkey
in between a hot topic and a sunglass
hut would you guys do you know you
picked the safe route didn't you oh I'm
gonna get an education now who's
laughing now as you sit there in your
four-bedroom colonial next to your
tandup wife shot out three [__] kids
still has a flat stomach cuz you got
enough money to suck the fat out of her
stomach with a I love you baby
liposuction gift certificate that's all
empty I'm telling you guys you haven't
[__] lived until you're across from a
Sears & Roebuck in a gym you know and
catty-corner from a [__] JCPenney and
you stood there and you told your
unresearched jokes I can't [__] wait
to do this gig last night I went out to
flappers I swear to god that's the name
of a comedy club flappers in Burbank and
I think that that's an old showbiz term
that meant dancing [__] in the
vaudeville days and I went out there and
I had a great goddamn time there's
something I'm working on in my
right now I'm not gonna tell you guys
what it is all right cuz that would be
like advice [__] showed you the rabbit
I put it in the Hat and then say watch
me pull a rabbit out of the Hat you know
I'm sure I use that example before but
you know what why don't you wing a
podcast a [__] hour every goddamn
week and let me see if you don't repeat
stories Jesus the attitude of you people
this week on a goddamn holiday Stan yeah
this is basically what you do it you
treat stand-up just like a [__]
athlete would all right look at Dirk
Nowitzki didn't he have some sort of
problem with his game I don't even know
what the [__] it is I don't know what
the [__] he does let's let's pick Shaq
all right let's say sure if Shaq was a
stand-up comedian he would not have
changed a joke for 20 years of doing
stand-up all right he sucked at shooting
file taking file shots at the beginning
of his career and he sucked at the end
of it he didn't work on his goddamn game
all right
he was a big goof he dunked the ball and
he slammed his nuts in people's faces he
did it from day one right into the end
of his [__] career everyone knew he
was gonna do it more of the same Shaq
and then he got other people they adjust
their [__] game so as me I don't know
what to do what am I supposed to do with
my act I've already done two hour-long
specials I gotta try something new so
I'm going into new uncharted territory
and I've been I've been I've been doing
the work I can use the left hand now I
can hold the left the mic in the left
hand now basically is what the [__] does
it was that even remotely interesting I
don't know what the hell I'm talking
about all I know is I'm excited that I
am back in Los Angeles after last week
when I was put on punishment on my own
goddamn podcast and I'll tell you I will
never forgive New Jersey for that in my
four years of doing a podcast I have
never been so insulted by a poor excuse
for a state in my entire life the
[__] nerve the [__] nerve of the
hotel system out there and in
Brunswick New Jersey to treat me like
that if you can you think I'm ever gonna
go back out there and grace that [__]
stage you are absolutely correct cuz I'm
a [__]
I'm always gonna do it I don't give a
[__] I don't care if you make me whisper
my entire [__] podcast I will come
back to whatever mall you have and I
will tell jokes cuz what the what else
am I gonna do you know you can't
parachute out of this [__] job you
can't tell jokes for 20 [__] years
that that decide that you're gonna be a
lawyer or kanya I don't [__] know all
I know is lately I lately I've had I had
a number of people from from the past
like people I haven't seen in like 15
years will come walking up to me and be
like hey yeah remember me remember we
did stand-up back when Kurt Cobain was
still alive and I'd be like oh yeah yeah
and then they'll tell ya you know I'm
thinking about getting back into it and
I always whenever they say that to me I
want to grab the nearest blunt object
and start smashing them over the head
with it you know that's like don't you
why the [__] would you ever get into
this awful business in your 40s why
would you ever do that I could see being
dumb in your 20s people are gonna love
me that's what you're supposed to think
of your 20s then you [__] get in
there you see what it really is standing
in a mall sliding into 50 wide I swear
to god the next [__] from my
stand-up past who comes up to me telling
me that they were smart enough to get
out of this goddamn business they got
married they had kids they got a [__]
job and now for some reason they're
thinking of throwing that all in the
[__] and getting back in this goddamn
business I swear to God I am gonna buy
one Jackie Onassis glove that goes right
up to my elbow and I'm gonna put it on
really slowly and then slowly I'm gonna
take it off and I'm gonna
slap him across the [__] face with it
are you out of your goddamn mind don't
you realize that most of us end up on
cruise ships why would you do that to
your family alright you were smart
enough to leave
okay so there's anybody for my stand-up
past who's listening to this and it's
thinking about getting back in this
business
let me tell you you made the right
decision okay Jesus Christ
alright I think what the [__] I'm
talking about here alright let's let's
tell a couple of stories I went to a
[__] awesome wedding this weekend it
was actually an after party this couple
did it perfectly they eloped
bing-bang-boom they got [__] married
and they announced it everybody was
excited for him and then they had a
[__] after-party like three months
later they have this after-party
everybody gets dressed up they got a
permit they go to the park it's [__]
free and all everybody has to do was
just bring food and if you traveled they
said just bring drinks and if your
birthday was in June make desserts and
that was it and we went there we had a
great [__] time they had a talent
show and everybody was going up and it
was all these people who could sing and
play you know guitars and stuff and they
were singing these songs celebrating
this couple finding love and getting
married one of those awesome awesome
[__] receptions that actually makes
you want to get married you know what I
mean you know those once you go to were
you just sitting there going oh Jesus I
give this about three months oh I've
told this story before I'll go [__]
yourselves that time I went to that met
that wedding and the groom was toasting
the his his wife his bride and he was
like searching for words he's like I'd
like to toast my wife for granting me I
was just everybody just staring down at
the [__] half-eaten chicken was awful
but this was the opposite this was
awesome
they were both glowing they were excited
and their parents were happy and it was
[__] great so and the food was was
great somebody brought like a bunch of
in-and-out burgers it was the [__] all
right was the best goddamned wedding I
ever went to me and Nia went we had a
great [__] time so we're saying that
we're watching all these talented people
going up there some people being funny
some people singing these really great
songs and it was just awesome and all of
it was in celebration of this couple
finding love okay and then all of a
sudden this [__] leg goes up to the
mic all right right off the bat just to
give you a little advice I'm not ill
advice a little description she's
wearing a pretty much see-through dress
like if you're close enough you can see
her bra and panties but there's enough
of a pattern where they're not totally
exposed but there's not enough of a
pattern that you can't see her bra and
panties so right off the bat she's given
you know what I mean it's like when when
when a defensive tackle figures out
whatever the quarterbacks tick is and
can figure out if it's a runner of pass
it's the same thing she went up there
with her bra and panties exposed right
there she's saying I am gonna try and
steal focus and make this [__] all about
me but you know nobody really saw it
coming so she walks up there and after
everybody is sitting at this wonderful
[__] wedding that is celebrating
these two wonderful people finding love
she goes up there and this is her opener
she goes up and on the mic she goes I
think I deserve a round of applause
because I'm the one who set these two
people up that's how she starts there's
an awkward pause awkward silence and
then people just sort of clap like okay
and then she proceeds to tell a story of
how she met the glue her and the groom
where this is she started to tell the
story how she set up the bride and the
groom and she starts talking about how
the groom he just got out of this
treacherous relationship member she kept
using that word treacherous relationship
I had also gotten out of a treacherous
relationship she starts bringing up exes
okay she already made it about herself
she got a [__] round of applause and
then she took a bow like she was like we
decided to applaud her like she was
mocking the applause it's like no [__]
you [__] asked for it
alright then she brings up this dude's
exes and then she starts talking about
how when she introduced the two of them
they talked for like an hour and
afterwards I said to the bride so what
did you think she got you know nice guy
and then I said I think he's really into
you into you and then I and then she
said oh he was into me I thought he was
gay so she brings up the groom
questioning basically his sexuality and
it was a [__] masterpiece ten minutes
of just she steered the wedding into the
Sun and she came out the other [__]
side and everyone was on fire after it
was it was it was so [__] horrific
you know what it reminded me of it
reminded me of back in the day when I
first started doing stand-up and I was
working the Kowloon the Chinese
restaurant up on Route one in Saugus do
get a [__] poopoo platter kid [__]
scorpion balls shows how far I've come
I've come from working upstairs at a
Chinese restaurant to working in a mall
in Columbus Ohio I actually love that
[__] Gaghan when I'm in the club I
feel like I'm in a comedy club but when
I walk out you know
oh god I'm across from a [__] dick
sporting good it just it just kills it
for me so anyways plowing you had it
what that that that lady did it reminded
me of when I first started off doing
comedy and I was sitting at the back of
his Knicks comedy stop at the kowloon
and I was in the back and I was watching
these guys who have been doing it for
like five six years
I was in awe of this game that they were
playing because I was so new I would go
on stage and all I wanted was the crowd
to like me so I could somehow not get
heckled not get booed and survive
another day and his [__] brutal
business but these guys you know they
knew what the [__] they were doing so
they were playing this game where you
would go on stage and the first thing
out of your mouth you had to completely
make turn the crowd off you had to make
the crowd [__] hate you
absolutely [__] hate you and then you
immediately go right into your act and
you never addressed what the [__] you
said you never say that it was a joke
you just don't address it and then you
try and see if you can get him back and
it was [__] hilarious but it was
really hard to find that perfect thing
to say to make everybody immediately
[__] hate you begin what most comics
did was they went so far that what they
said was so over-the-top and so
ridiculous that the crowd knew they
weren't serious and they would actually
laugh it's that I swear to god it's like
a tightrope
I don't know that you can do it on
purpose but this lady at the wedding was
the greatest I've ever seen anybody do
that she walked up there and within
after I think I deserve a round of
applause
immediately I hated her and you felt it
everybody did not everybody I'm speaking
I'm projecting here but I think some
people they're just too good of human
beings to just hate someone like that or
even suspect they're just such good
people that they would never suspect
that somebody would try to make a moment
like that about themselves then you got
a jaded [__] like me okay and I see
through this [__] just like I can see
right through her [__] dress and but
I have to tell you the more I thought
about it it was it was a was actually it
was almost like performance art so now
that I feel like I've told this story
way too [__] long but if you guys
have any stories like that like the you
know this Steve basically The Steve
Buscemi character and Adam Sandler's the
wedding crasher that's basically what I
was watching and if you guys have any
great stories like that like really
unique ones I don't want to hear the
ones
he got drunk and he said something
stupid I think those have been done to
death unless you have a really unique
story or possibly video of it I'd love
to see it but anyways so then she ended
up getting off and uh and then they that
the ceremony continued he knew it was
[__] tremendous I actually had a
couple of those moments this weekend you
know I was like I said I'm off my diet
kind of a [__] man am i that I'm
talking about being on a goddamn diet
what happened you know why you know what
I love about the greatest generation is
when you walk down the street you say
hello to them they enthusiastically say
hello back to you I [__] love old
people walking down the street with my
dog Cleo
right we had just gone up on a hike and
I see this old older fellas walking the
other way and he's looking right at me
and I said hey Gomorrah and he goes hey
good morning to Utah where are you you
know nice little conversation made you
feel like you were in the beginning of
like a Disney movie right and then like
another thirty yards down the street
there's someone from like my generation
so am i you know that guy put a [__]
song in my heart I'm half skipping down
the street I see this person my age I'm
like hey are you doing and the person
was just like yeah mumbled some shits
like you know like we get hit by a
[__] car so anyways as I said I'm off
my diet and I was coming back home from
the club you know cuz I eat like [__]
when I was on the road and I'm on the
crack right now I got the sugar and salt
porn through my system and I'm driving
home and I just want to go home and my
[__] body's going go into the
supermarket by a vat of ice cream and
[__] stick it in your piehole you
know so I'm a weak individual I pull
into Ralph's the worst name ever for a
grocery store
Ralph's slang for puking and you sell
food right now I never thought that the
[__]
how big is your goddamn ego Ralph that
you still named it after yourself so
anyways I go into this place and I I get
the [__] ice cream and as I'm
standing up there I see there's this
impulse buy things it says the top
whatever [__] twenty places to get
breakfast in Los Angeles and they got on
the cover they got this goddamn egg ham
bacon and cheese sandwich on a buttery
biscuit
it just looked absolutely delicious like
I said I'm on the crack you know if I
was eating oatmeal and having the salads
and all that type of [__] I would look
at it and that food wouldn't even make
sense to me you know but because I got
the salt and sugar in my veins right now
I'm fiending I was like I'm buying that
[__] magazine if I could eat that
cover right now I would so I buy the
magazine I come home I show it to my
lady right and I got all this list of
the best [__] places to get breakfast
in Los Angeles and so we decide we're
gonna pick one out we're gonna go there
the next day and I got to tell you
something I got I got an overrated for
you overrated picking up a [__]
magazine that lists ten great places to
go to breakfast and then believing that
no one else read the magazine and
there's not going to be a line three
miles long the next [__] morning when
you show up to get your pancakes that's
exactly what happened we pull up and I
see this [__] looks like a goddamn
bread line during the Depression and I'm
with Nia and her mom and I immediately
just go hey yeah you guys want to go
somewhere else and then somebody in the
car goes well there's probably gonna be
a line everywhere right so we [__]
stand in line for forty minutes got to
the point I'm crouching down like a my
back is killing my lower back like I'm
so old I can't just stand for longer
than like 20 minutes without my lower
back killing me so I'm standing there 40
minutes in I'm crouching down like UFC
Asians when they have a conversation in
China how they just [__] they can
crouch down like that and or people in
India you know they crouch down like
that they've been doing it their whole
lives so their hamstrings are all
stretched out I was school
down like that my big head turn it all
red I'm trying to stand in a little bit
of the shade and I don't know finally I
was let's get the [__] out of here right
so everybody agreed we leave and we end
up going in me we stood in line for
breakfast so long it was now time to get
lunch so we end up going down we're on
Santa Monica and we go down into West
Hollywood and there's a place down there
hamburger Harry's they have great
[__] they got great burgers and it's
one of but it's also one of the gayest
places you'll ever go to you in your
life I didn't realize how gay it was and
I went there and the waiter was like
really gay or whatever but I didn't
really think about it right so I drop
off the ladies and I go over and I park
the car I get out of the car and I come
walking in and I'm starving and as I'm
walking in all sudden this guy pushes me
in the back like gave me a nice little
shove and I turn around and he goes do
you need a table this [__] gay dude
push me in the bag push me like [__]
down like not hard enough to make me
stumble but hard enough to [__] up the
gate of my walk and immediately you know
felt the feelings you feel when somebody
[__] pushes you when I turn around
like what the [__] and the guys just
stand there do you need a table and I
went no I'm just meeting them over there
and then he kinda had a weird look on
his face and he walked away and I sit
down and he's like hey how's it going
how's it go and I go that [__] gay
guy just pushed me so I tell her this
story and I'm oh my god what the [__] is
that some gay thing you just [__] go
around pushing people and then Nia goes
he was probably hitting on you right so
now my ego kicks in I'm like [__] I
still am in shape so for any of my
[__] twinkle-toed listeners out there
is that how you guys hit on each other
was that just like hey Philly do you
want a table is that what he was doing
it was [__] annoying whatever was
then I felt embarrassed and I felt bad
like like that look on his face when I
went now I'm sitting over here like then
he thought that I I don't know what that
I was saying get out of here you queer
you know cuz that's a whole big [__]
thing now you got to be nice to those
guys what the [__] I'm saying it so
anyways so we sit down and all right and
immediately a dude comes over hi can I
take your order we [__] order and
we're getting our food immediately the
way you should when you go out to eat so
now despite the fact that [__] that
the waiter pushed me like that dude who
pushed Zdeno Chara after he scored the
goal that's basically how he pushed me
and then I turned around and looked at
him like I was gonna run him into the
boards basically right so they [__]
bring the food over it's delicious
everything's going great and then all of
a sudden this [__] dude gets on the
mic and you can't see him he's like okay
everybody show thought a good ten
minutes right and I say Nia go what's
going on she goes evidently they're
gonna have a show oh it's [__] broad
daylight out I guess they're gonna come
out and drag and they're gonna do a show
like this is this is how gay this place
is that they're gonna have a brunch
slash transvestite lip-sync [__] show
and I got to tell you it was absolutely
[__] hilarious
we were sitting there and the guy on the
mic it's like 11:30 in the morning and
he said [__] on the mic he goes come on
[__]
drink up we're having a show don't be a
bunch of something I go sorry I'm sorry
I'm just feeling a little kunti there
with Mia's mom and this guy starts
saying [__] like every other [__]
word in broad daylight and as a comedian
I had to respect the gun all right I've
never said [__] on stage when the sun's
out I'm not gonna lie to you I barely
say it on stage I say it a ton of times
here cuz it's ridiculous but I really
don't say it that much on a comedy club
stage and this dude slash half Ali is
saying [__] every other word at brunch
and so anyway so they come down like
three of them
the hosts sucked right he had this giant
head with this huge [__] I don't know
what blonde wig on and he he was like
doing jokes that should have been funny
but weren't at some point he said
something about a bloody [__] and we
sitting here eating brunch and he makes
a bloody [__] joke so just as a
comedian this should have been hilarious
but timing was awful he'd say the setup
and then he'd mumbled the punchline and
he was annoying me the next one came out
was all right the dude looked like Nancy
Grace so that was cracking me up and
then the next one looked like a soccer
mom if if she was in Battlestar
Galactica you know you know when they
have those you know they get that
Woodstock Ellen DeGeneres haircut kind
of had that but spiked up and that was
hilarious and then the last one freaked
me out there's always one that's gonna
freak you out because it's gonna almost
look like a [__] chick so it had like
ass in plants and it's like I'm trying
to eat like I gotta get out of here so I
go up I walk out of the restaurant cuz
you know it's one of those deals you
it's like when in Rome you went into
that place you gotta tolerate then it
becomes this that point we just like
alright this is this is too [__]
creepy I gotta get out of here you know
so I walk out and I'm standing on the
corner out in front of this place that
turned into the gayest place I've ever
been in and I got to tell you I walk
down the street all the time in LA
nobody ever tells me that they saw me
nobody's ever seen me nothing I come
walking out of this place right and this
behind me is this some transvestite that
almost looks like a chick with ass in
plants and is dancing to salt and pepper
push it I swear to God so I'm standing
out in front of that place and it's that
part of the Sun was going push it turnin
on it and this guy pulls up from the
Comedy Store stop into the red light
he's like hey bill are you doing and I'm
just like hey how's it going
and the [__] background and my face
literally turned red with embarrassment
but fortunately fortunately the guy
owned a restaurant across the way so
then he ended up coming out coming over
to me coming out how [__] funny is
that he comes over to me and he goes you
know to shoot the [__] cuz I've been
telling I was gonna go to his restaurant
and that just then fortunately Nia and
her mom walked out and I've never been
so relieved to be like this is my
girlfriend and this is mom I didn't know
that there was gonna be a [__] it was
like a like a mid-80s
I don't know what a mid eighties uh
sitcom you know where there's a
situation did that even make sense ain't
Nia we see if I can get her in here for
a second hang on a second all right here
we go I just hit pause I brought the
lovely Nia in once again the lovely Nia
coming back to the podcast how are you
sweetheart I'm doing good I'm telling
the story of how I just got done telling
the story of how we went to that you
know that brunch place in the end right
there was the unbelievably long bread
line remember that and I was crouching
down my back was killing me so then we
went down to hamburger Harry's and all
of a sudden the transvestite Oh
Hamburger Mary's whatever okay no there
was a place in New York called hamburger
Harry so maybe maybe that's what it was
but I was just telling listeners I was
never so [__] relieved as when you
and you and your mom came out after that
[Laughter]
it was awesome but that that last that
last dude [__] freaked me out that
was too weird I don't mind like
transvestites are [__] hilarious to
me especially if they're a little bit
angry you know why was I born with the
dick if that was [__] the underlining
thing of all their comedy is [__]
hilarious to me they're actually used to
be a [__] [__]
stand-up in New York went by the name of
Sharon Needles mm-hmm like sharing
needles right if she was are he whatever
the [__] you supposed to say it's a he
say he it doesn't what what what why
does it hurt you to say the pronoun that
they would prefer because I feel like I
feel like I am respectful of the fact
that they want to be called she or he it
does it's it feels phony it feels like
wait why can't I say how I feel about it
you're talking over me here it really
makes you feel like oh I'm living alive
by you like come on I can't sit there
you're like oh she knowing that he's got
a [__] dick and balls it's a guy in a
dress and I just feel like you get
[__] sitting it's like you're sitting
there with an alkie and you're acting
like they're not an alkie oh and you're
gonna sit there and enable them now
that's not what do you know I gotta be
honest I don't know why it just makes it
just it's weird well fine but maybe it's
weird for you but don't compare people
being transgendered so being alcoholics
cuz it's not the same thing why at all
it's a lot of guy who was an alcoholic
and exactly he's not an alcoholic I am
I've never been that serious
that's the podcast nothing everything so
[__] thing is a joke so anyways this
dude used to go up there and address
Sharon Needles and would go out was
absolutely [__] hilarious for some
reason stop doing it but the dude was
hilarious you liked Murray Hill too
remember Murray Hill we went to go see
Dita Von Teese and Murray Hill was the
emcee ah I was so disappointed with that
[__] show she was hilarious he she
shits [__] shake he got a vajayjay
where were you know you were born in
Murray Hill no she was [__] hilarious
he saved the show but the [__] we go
down there well who is lose the lady the
lady who was dancing that night
Livan to use yeah so this [__] the
girl used to be married to uh Marilyn
Manson yes so Nia goes hey Bill you want
to come down to this show it's gonna be
a burlesque show this girl's [__] hot
she's gonna be prancing around in her
underwear right I'm like
abso-fucking-lutely
what a great idea I would love to go do
it and I went down there thinking that
this was just gonna be sort of an
upscale titty bar show and I went down
there and it was the gay it was all gay
guys and those two douche bags making
out it was [__] gross it was a little
much it was [__] gross they were
straight it was straight if they were
straight make it out like that it was
[__] gross yeah it was it was they
were on their way to having sex
it was too much yeah I thought the whole
thing was was false advertising because
you shown some ladies gonna go in there
and strip down to her [__] hoo-hah
you think you're gonna be going in there
it's gonna bunch of guys going it's a
totally different crowd I didn't realize
that now you know now I know so anyways
you know I think I [__] up I should
have brought you in as I told the story
I I decided for some dumb reason to tell
the story first and then bring you in
during the epilogue this is like the end
of like chips right now we're supposed
to tell the joke and then laugh and then
they freeze us okay
so we've decided that we're gonna visit
these other hot breakfast places that
they have out here yeah but we're gonna
do it on days when people have to go to
work that's right we're not gonna go on
weekends what is this about what is this
charge message just become right now
this is really just become a [__]
relationship podcast we have to get out
of this you know what let's let's do
some advice here oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
bring it
who was your favorite transvestite of
the show I told
with the acid plants that was fun free
she was hot
it's a guy up you know something I wish
that why are you yelling because that's
what I do cuz I wasn't allowed to yell
last week it's the only way I'm funny I
have to yell I have to curse I have to
say it is a crutch it's what I do it's
my thing it's my hook see huh you know I
wish I wish that last [__] lady that
you're saying dropped his [__]
coochie cutters and his junk just
spilled out just to watch the look in
your face and you says alright you have
a little consideration of my [__]
listeners it's just supposed to be it
was supposed to be a funny story about
me walking out and standing in front of
basically a gay bar and then somebody
[__] drives by being outed as a
patron of Hamburger Mary's the first
time we went there you got outed by
somebody that's right the [__] Berg
is delicious what do you want every time
I go there that's right every time I go
there that was hilarious
and that dude was going so what are you
doing here I'm here getting a burger on
he goes do you live in this neighborhood
he was totally out you know what I've
never been married
I don't have any kids I'm still in shape
I mean I'm [__] having burgers in
West Hollywood I mean Jesus Christ
it's all there bunch of red flags all
right here's uh do I dare read this one
with you in the [__] room no no this
is one about a threesome
Oh oh yeah let's talk about let's go
with let's go with still a virgin
hola bill my younger brother and I have
been having this debate about whether he
took his girlfriend's virginity oh I
thought this is gonna be about a guy
who's still a virgin
all right this might get ugly all right
my brother and I have been having this
debate about whether he took his
girlfriend's virginity basically my
brother who is now 20 has been dating
the same chick
since they met in Catholic High School
he says his girlfriend is saving herself
for marriage like a good Catholic my
brother on the other hand lost his
virginity before they met so get this
get a load of this guy's right there
like it's a 20 here's the kick I say
instead of typical [__] this chick
lets my brother [__] her in the ass
let's read that again so get this get a
load of this instead of typical [__]
this chick lets my brother [__] her in
the ass and furthermore she has
convinced him that she is still a virgin
I tell my brother first consider
yourself lucky because most women will
never let you do that and second this
chick is not only a [__] [__] but is
[__] royally stupid according to her
Catholic standards if you only have anal
sex then you're still a virgin this is
complete horseshit it's sad to me
because I know this isn't an isolated
incident but rather a growing phenomenon
what websites are you going to sir it
appears that more and more so-called
Catholic school goody two-shoe [__]
have been brainwashed to think that they
are holy in the eyes of the Lord by
maintaining their virginity even though
they spread their butt cheeks and show
the ahright ahright please bill for the
love of all that is holy help me can
help me to convince not only my brother
but all these so-called children of God
that even if you don't [__] a girl in
their vagina that a girl loses her
Virginia Virginia virginity when when
she gets banged in the
this is the problem with lack of sexual
education in this country particularly
when it comes to like Catholic school
before you get on your soapbox do you
feel I just knocked you off do you feel
that this woman is still a virgin no
she's not a virgin no even though when
you go to put it in her her hymen broken
hymen is in place
it's basically but the seal hasn't been
broken on the bottle but you screwed in
the bottom and all the liquid is poured
out and then you do one of them will
this most skankiest sex act you could
possibly do why is that skanky look they
shouldn't be demonized one way or
another and I take umbrage with this guy
calling this girl a [__] just because
she's having anal sex okay are you a
[__] because you bang girls shut the
[__] up that's wrong that's the wrong
way to look at it why because she took
it in the age doesn't make them [__]
it's a sex act yeah but it's a dirty
filthy one well that's your issue and
people need to let that go but as far as
him they'll be it doesn't matter matter
what he does he's never gonna be a [__]
he's a guy listen yeah I'll explain it
to you this way if you take that
patronizing tone with me you don't well
you are to use the word umbrage yeah
because I'm smart
don't get all right you're all right I
don't know what umbrage I take umbrage I
take umbrage with the fact that you used
umbrage and didn't warn me that you're
gonna do that didn't you see the look in
my eyes the [__] is it was this Meet the
Press
no what I've heard a lot of girls are
thinking that it's not regular sex but
it's all sex people okay let's let's
look like a drug a drug way okay and a
drug sense okay all right make it out
that's like you had a beer getting felt
up you smoked the joint
going to third go in a second where at
what facing my own right now
third going to third is like you just
did some blow and getting [__] no wait
I went all over the place I lost my
train of thought
okay good yeah if it was like drugs okay
first base is drinking second base is
weed third base is coke
maybe shrooms
it's shrooms home is coke and then
getting banged in the ass is heroin with
some meth that's like you're not coming
back
alright so she skipped that's what she
did she went from just sort of drinking
and smoking some weed and went straight
to meth it's beyond Nene it's beyond you
ran past home plate you went into the
dugout you kept going past the showers
and you ran right out of the [__]
stadium and the girl that he's [__]
why don't you worry about getting your
own piece of tail he actually agrees
with you he agrees with you that there's
there's a misinformation out here yeah
but he's directing it towards the girls
that are doing it not the people who
come up with these rules to begin with
which is what I want I'm standing up I'm
walking around if he's really I'm about
ready to drop some knowledge all right
here you go they just never stop this is
why this is why if a guy does it he's
not a [__]
if a woman does it she is okay this is
first of all why it's it's not a big
deal if a guy engages in that act it's
basically it's because we enter you know
ural you allow somebody to enter your
body
that's that's like so much more than
like what the [__] we do that's why sex
is not a big deal to us I've told you
now here before that basically a well
basically like this is the deal if
somebody said hey I'll give you a
thousand bucks to go over to that
doesn't say there's a birthday cake give
me a thousand bucks to go over there and
just stick your finger in it uh-huh
you do it in a second right yeah if
somebody said I'll give you a thousand
bucks to take that cake and shove it up
your ass
all right you'd have some questions
where is that cake been what do I get
out of it
you didn't negotiate for more [__]
money so that's the same thing that's
just what we do sticking up fingers and
cakes that's that's that's how much sex
means to us
I think that's [__] well I don't
expect you to understand it about my
comprehend that's why you guys that's
why you guys think way more about who
you're gonna have sex with because you
letting somebody enter your [__] body
now I'm just walking around I'm poking
people now it's conditioning it's not
it's you you grew up with this idea that
you're supposed to not feel a certain
way if you use the word Society I swear
to God
we're just brainwashed from day one that
what we do is wrong you I have had an
emotional moment why are you making it
sound like I cried or something during I
never did that no no you never did so
why did you just say that you just
making [__] up
you went from I'm sure there's guys out
there there's no research behind that
and then you just threw that out there
would you like me to talk about my
research or would that make you
uncomfortable oh this is World Series of
Poker you just went all in now I got to
figure out if you're bluffing or nut am
I gonna call your hand
oh you're staring right at me you
[__] pain in the ass I'm folding I'm
folding why do you always do this to me
on the podcast do what this is a second
tell you on your bull
did you ever do that again I'm saying
that nodding with your eyebrows they're
calling you in your [__] ah the
[__] ego of females you guys are just
always patting yourselves on the back
are you
let me tell you something right now yeah
yeah if you were a [__] dude right
now I'd kick you in the chest and watch
you fall right off the bed but I can't
do it cuz that's what you deserve right
now but I can't do it because you're
only you know what I love about yelling
in this [__] apartment is I love that
it bugs that old [__] downstairs
okay and I know that he calls I'm
whispering again like I'm back in
Brunswick I'm having a Vietnam flashback
I love that he calls and complaints and
I love that the landlord doesn't give a
[__] because we play we pay like 90
times what that guy pays yeah exactly
the end of the day so that's you know
we're like we're like a [__]
superpower up here and he's a
third-world country
and he's down there picking the coffee
beans and we're coming in taking them
all and tell him to go back to his
[__] Hut you know and then my
landlord is buying into the fact that
we're actually helping him to become
free right yeah yeah I can't remember if
I already said that on this podcast
because I started and stopped this thing
so when he was let's let's let's move on
let's move on to an another one it's
about threesomes Nia okay you stop
rubbing your feet together she has this
thing where she just always is rubbing
her feet together
it's called soothing my world is called
jerking off oh all right hi Bill how are
you um I'm a big fan out of Edmonton
Alberta Canada I've been up there
Northlands Coliseum on the greatest
hockey team on the great okay you got
fans up here so pull a louis c.k and
come up
I guess Louie was just up there some
good food some good beer that you no
longer drink and some women that I feel
put Montreal de shame oh [__] I like
that huh I like the ladies okay
meet some advice and if you felt like
bringing in the lovely Nia
then by all means do so as a woman's
thoughts would be very welcomed alright
here we go my fiancée my fiancée my
fiancee from Virginia told me recently
that one of her fantasies is a threesome
with another thing is whenever I bring
it up she gets squeamish about it I've
come across two separate women that have
said they're interested in her as ni is
a couple but when it was time to meet my
fiancee pretty much said she didn't want
to once was due to my fiancee being 3
months pregnant with our jurors AG horn
we don't judge on the podcast really
hilarious but how inappropriate would it
be to have a well I wonder how that
would damage the kid the kid is in there
and he can hear like become a porn star
you never seen that thing when people
read books to the womb and the kick
comes out and all of a sudden you can do
calculus calculus you never see that
you'll be playing music to the kid comes
out he's like [__] the mos'ly anyway
just keep reading what's it like a
little tadpole in there looks like at
that point that's when the baby the baby
looks like a little t-rex those [__]
alien heads all right once it was due to
my fiance being 3 months pregnant with
our firstborn and the second time was
because I had a crush on said woman well
Jesus Christ give yourself a dog in the
fight sir so what gives these guys a
[__] this guy is a [__]
I don't get what's going on what's the
problem
Wow she's fond of girl girl porn when
she rubs one out makes comments when
we're in public about
other women being attractive sexually so
she portrays herself as into them yet
she doesn't pursue her supposed fantasy
and when I bring it up
she seems put off about the whole thing
should I keep trying to make it happen
or just throw in the towel oh yeah it's
going really good so far
hey we give people hope during the
advice section she's most likely she's
most likely saying well if he didn't
need it didn't need help he wouldn't he
wouldn't rent wrote in and she's most
likely saying she's into the three way
to appease me and some warped twisted
woman way thanks for the advice go [__]
yourself ah all right here we go here we
go all right dude there's a bunch of
stuff going on here
first of all yet I can't really say that
those were attempts when you tried to
have a threesome when your what your
fiancee was three months pregnant with
the baby and then secondly the fact that
you're attracted to the other yet you're
not not attracted you had a crush on the
other woman this there's rules to having
a [__] threesome you know you can't
yeah you can't have feelings for the
other woman and for the most part you
can't climax with the other one that's
also a problem from what I've heard I've
never had one I never I never had you
know what twice in my life I could have
had a threesome when I was younger but I
was too [__] stupid to realize it was
going on I just never seen that going
like why won't her girlfriend leave I'm
trying to get laid here then another
time I was working in Buffalo and these
girls just put it on the table they put
it on the table they basically said
we're like a coalition I remember they
used that word and one was hot and the
other one looked like a three-story
brownstone she was a [__] she like a
building she was like a was like six
three there was a guy used to play for
[__] the Portland Trailblazers
duckworth that's what she looked like
with the vagina and I was just like you
know I never had you know what I never
had that ability I never had that
ability
just bang something that I wasn't
attracted to it was just always
disgusting to me
so there you go so from what I've heard
sir I am NOT speaking from a place of
experience here but I will tell you this
if you're gonna have a [__] threesome
I wouldn't do it with someone who you're
in a relationship with I don't think the
relationship is ever the [__] same
and I don't know it's just it's just a
it's a weird thing well I think like the
issue that he's having with his fiancee
he's just marrying her because he
knocked her up is that she talks about
wanting to be with women but it's not
acting on it but a lot of times you know
people have these sexual fantasies and
they're just meant to be fantasy yeah
they're not really necessarily gonna be
a reality like just because you you know
in your mind's eye or like ooh that
would be interesting doesn't ya actually
gonna go through like a lot of women has
the gangbang fantasy that doesn't mean
they're gonna go into a [__] loading
dock and lay down and be like who wants
it right sorry I have male listeners I
have to get to the point here yeah so
that doesn't necessarily mean it you
actually gonna want to do it and your
methods of trying to go about it are
just so off the mark it's like alright
well you know let's say I wanted to have
a threesome with you mm-hmm
alright yep which I do I don't I do in
my head but I don't I don't want to do
it because it's gonna [__] everything up
you really think so
yes it's gonna be [__] weird it's
gonna be weird it's you know what it is
Nia you [__] you cross too many you
open to many Pandora's box or whatever
the [__] expression is you never come
back you don't come back and it's and
it's like you have to start over again
you'd have to I don't know you know it's
like we were talking about Madonna I'm a
Madonna when they were playing like that
was another thing to to add to the
gayness of that bar they were playing
Madonna videos and you were talking
about her getting [__] divorced yeah
I was thinking her taste in men how she
likes those was I was saying like when
she wants a husband she goes for like us
that the alpha male white guy
right you know usually very like a macho
strongman right but then when she has
her lover's that's when she has a
20-something year old latino boy that no
one's ever little boy so here's the
thing this girl is sold out [__]
Madison Square Garden she's already done
the [__] astronaut tour you know the
astronauts they go around the [__]
world they see how beautiful it is and
then they start crying at a stoplight
you know they see too much it's the same
thing with her she's seen too much so
there's no way she's ever gonna be able
to keep a marriage going because at any
moment as she has to sit there and be
unselfish and listen to this [__]
square headed white guy yes that she
likes likes we're headed white guys
right so the guys going like you know
what [__] give me what I need at any
moment she can pull the ripcord still
sell out Madison Square Garden yeah and
then go bang some [__] stud uh-huh it
fetish guy mm-hmm if I had those options
new you think I'd be listening to you Oh
point I could go in and [__] trade
your ass in for some [__] 22 year old
just start blowing me immediately please
I'd be out of here a second anyway yeah
the worst [__] talking of everybody yeah
see I'd like to see you try it why I
oughta
yeah why don't you let your stop having
a jerk tone to this guy yeah he'll come
out sooner I was well I was gonna say
why don't you let you're the person that
you're in the relationship with it why
don't you let her lead the way on this
because now you're just becoming like
bad advice
that's guy that's putting all this
pressure on her just let her just let
her open the door to it if she wants to
if not leave it alone there's no need to
keep pushing it this is what you do this
is what because you don't know what
you're talking about yes I do know what
I'm talking about you don't
okay here's I have self-esteem and I
like myself all right this is the deal
all right [__] this you want this to
happen sir this is what you got to do
all right
if you will if you listen to Nia and you
let her lead the way it's never gonna
happen okay because she's not gonna act
on it the next time you find someone who
finds you guys
active as a couple do not tell you
[__] fiance about it alright
you tell the girl that's into it listen
you gotta [__] make it look natural
sort of coerce her into it in that type
of thing you just make it seem like it's
now yeah you go yeah you go up to the
bar and then you just make it seem like
it happened naturally and then you never
tell her the [__] secret and then
that's it that's how you do it because
right she's not gonna take the lead and
this guy is all [__] knees and elbows
she was pregnant and I had a crush on
the other girl what Gibbs yeah
no just the next time that there's a
girl that's [__] interested in you as
a couple don't tell your wife about it
and then go up there and just have her
[__] strike up a conversation and
just say listen do not flirt with me at
all
just flirt with her and get her [__]
motor running and then maybe they'll go
down and then what you want to do is try
to start the kissing there at the bar
thank you thank you see that's how you
do it because it that this I'm telling
you it's it's not gonna happen she's
like I like if I get scared it's not
gonna happen so you got you got to make
it seem like it's natural yeah that's
how you do it you got to get sneaky
there sir if that's what I just
advocated fair enough fair enough once
in a while she agrees with me
what else what else is there all right
you're not gonna like this one yeah this
one this was some guy talking to me
about sports this is the last thing and
then I gotta have the podcast here
because I got [__] to [__] do hi Bill
I'm gonna [__] with your little world
here buddy
this guy's coming real arrogant I'm
gonna scope I'm going straight to the
shit-talking then maybe I'll qualify my
statements with some buttering up you
smug [__] all right I do not understand
your fanatic fandom of professional
sports yet deplore the existence of
large corporations and bankers this is
an oxymoron because professional sports
are big corporations financed by
international banks / bankers I didn't
know that I thought they were
mom-and-pop stores this is gonna I'm
gonna go out on a limb and say this it's
gonna be really informative the players
are
commodities that these corporations buy
and sell on the exchange oh he's doing a
little parallel comparison there you
[__] [__] this is this is you know I
love about this is if he just did this
to piss me off this is so [__]
condescending the players have no
attachment to anything they go where
they make the most money do they really
I never noticed that all these years of
watching people go into free agency god
this is fascinating
sports franchises in quote by the way
that is a business term and has nothing
to do with sports are run there listen
to this Nia this is very informative
they're actually run by executives like
CEOs CFOs etc did you believe that I had
no idea they only care about the
financial performance of that
corporation as their bonuses are
directly tied to it that's horseshit
that's horseshit not if it's family-run
Steinbrenner's don't care about that
they want to win they want to win first
obviously they want to make money so you
know you're speaking in generalizations
all right players bonuses are directly
related to their performances on the
field why is he explain this to me
how could you hate corporations bankers
etc and have a love for professional
sports as they are the same thing well
because the New England Patriots never
spilled nine zillion gallons of oil into
the [__] Gulf of Mexico and then
refused to [__] clean it up without
the government bailing him out that's
why sir that's why that's why I
understand that they're corporations I
understand that it's a business and I
understand that how would I not
understand how especially after this
year after they went on strike and
they're talking about how the Players
Union had a collective bargaining
bargaining agreement and how the owners
agreed to it in 2006 and then decided
that they weren't getting a big enough
slice of the pie so they just basically
took their stadiums and went home and
then suggested that they play 18 games a
year rather than 16 clearly not giving a
[__] about the players and treating them
just like commodities I totally
understand that sir but this is the
thing sports I guess if you were really
going to be the one thing that I will
say about the corporations I don't like
I don't like when they hold the town
hostage and say
this a new stadium or we're leaving I
always think the city should be like
yeah well [__] leave and then every
other cities to say well we're not gonna
build you one
so now what are you gonna do but that's
not gonna happen I understand sir
I get that they're corporations I get it
alright thank you for that that guy is
I think he's douche bag of the week he
really is he's comparing one world bank
one world currency and microchipping
people to the I don't know NFL football
the Vancouver Canucks evidently they're
just as bad as Chase Manhattan Bank
great point sir you got any others you'd
like to share alright this podcast went
off the rails alright I was gonna have
an overrated
underrated overweight I was gonna say
college football in September you know
when you watch a Nebraska played Bunker
Hill Community College you know and
they're favored by 72 points and
actually I saw a bunch of good games
this week Utah State almost beat Auburn
right you saw that game didn't you yeah
you know something I think I discovered
a way to annoy Nia but I've never even
thought of I'll just talk about sports
all right this podcast is like on a life
support right now well you know there's
a lot of female comics go on stage and
they think that they're doing well to
come on Willian with that I [__]
trash everybody what cuz they're [__]
women I can't trash them there's plenty
of funny female comics out there I just
made that joke go [__] yourself what are
you doing to the pole you just keep
bringing it down my best you know what
oh good enough for you alright that's it
that's the podcast for this week I am
gonna be at the funny bone in Columbus
Ohio this wait a minute what's
underrated huh
I didn't have an underrated Oh
underrated bringing your girlfriend in
on the [__] part no that's overrated
bring you've gone a [__] more
underrated working out you're underrated
overrated before you [__] say him I'm
gonna be at the funny bone Columbus Ohio
uh Friday Saturday and Sunday of this
week that's Friday September 2nd no what
am I talking about what's today's date
the fifth No September 9th 10th and 11th
I'm gonna be out there and then I'm
gonna be in the Largo cornet theater in
Los Angeles for two shows on Tuesday
September 13th and then the final thing
I got is Friday Saturday I'm gonna be at
the Wilbur theater in Boston
Massachusetts that is it that's the
podcast for this week thank you for
everybody for listening thank you guys
once again for all the donations I am
currently working on a new badass
website and I am gonna be updating all
kinds of stuff in my my technological
world so be looking for that in the next
month that is it go [__] yourselves I'll
talk to you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you